bailén usualmente sus discursos no suele
atacar al expresidente donald trump pero
centró este discurso en las grandes
mentiras que les presidente job ayer ha
tratado de impulsar tras perder la
elección le dijo que durante el 6 de
enero del año pasado el ex presidente se
quedó sentado en su escritorio mientras
sus simpatizantes se tomaban el
capitolio dijo que no era verdad que
estos simpatizantes eran patriotas dijo
que no pueden ser patriotas personas que
atacan a los policías que atacan a los
edificios institucionales y que atacan
también a los policías que fueron en
menciono byd en 140 heridos policías
durante ese día en el que se trataron de
tomar el capitolio también rechazó la
mentira de que los resultados
electorales no son creíbles y rechazó
esta mentira argumentando que no puede
ser verdad que el expresidente donald
trump argumenta que los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales no son
creíbles si precisamente ese mismo día
también se votó para las elecciones a
gobernadores a senadores a
representantes de la cámara esas sí
fueron creíbles entonces fue un dura
crítica a las mentiras que ha tratado
impulsar el ex presidente donald trump
frente al 6 de enero y las elecciones